it was never going to be an ordinary
birthday but there nothing about captain
now Colonel Tom's story has been normal
from the flying tribute and military
honors to the card from her majesty
birthdays don't get much better than
this did you ever imagine a few months
ago that there would be a fly past like
that for your bow it was amazing thought
I mean I enjoyed that and on his
birthday colonel tom has an important
message for us all please do remember
that things will get better as the song
says the Sun will shine and we'll never
walk alone truly I believe that to be
sure but things will get better it was
at Easter that the first card arrived
for Colonel Tom's birthday since then
they haven't stopped a hundred and fifty
thousand cards and Counting and as the
veteran turned a hundred this morning
the messages kept coming you're an
inspiration to results thank you
he's become a national treasure and a
bit of a beacon of hope and that's what
we hoped for I mean he is a treasure to
us and now we are so thankful that
everyone else can experience him as a
person what are you gonna do tomorrow
when all of this is over I think sleep
I think sleep is the answer to all of it
Colonel Tom had planned on having a
party for his hundredth it was a smaller
gathering but far more than he could
ever have imagined with sporting greats
keep up all the great we're making you
should be seriously proud of what you do
and unexpected messages we wish you a
very happy 100th birthday from front
rooms to classrooms up and down the
country this has become about much more
than one unlikely celebrity it's become
about hope for us all that one foot in
front of the other we'll get through
this strange time ally Fortescue Sky
News
[Music]